- I'm here at Einstein Bagels,
picking up the caffeinated bagels
that everybody is talking about.
(happy music)
- I call it double buzz.
They can have a coffee, and a
bagel with the caffeine in it.
- 32 milligrams of caffeine,
I read online that it's about
a third of a cup of coffee.
- Yes.
- That sound about right?
- Yes, that's about right.
- Fuck yeah, I drink
coffee every day for sure.
- You haven't drank coffee today though.
- No.
- Doesn't seem like it.
- I've already had two cups this morning.
- (laughs) Really?
- So I'm gonna be like,
Yeah!
- Yeah.
- I'm like imagining like,
those like, hipsters,
who like, drink coffee, and like,
eat this bagel at the same time.
- I'm actually excited
'cause I love bagels.
- Oh, I love bagels, I love coffee.
- You are slow right now.
(laughs)
- [Interviewer] You look very sleepy,
you sound very sleepy, you need caffeine.
- Please, give me caffeine.
(laughs)
(intense music)
- Mmm.
- Ooh, it looks good!
- Yeah it does!
- They smell chocolatey, smell it.
- Oh, they do smell chocolatey, wow!
- So we're gonna try
it plain and untoasted,
and then toasted with cream cheese.
- Yes.
- Cheers.
- I feel like the coffee's subtle.
- When I breathe out,
I get a little bit of that
bitterness in my sinuses.
- I'm bad at tasting things,
like I don't have a really
good sense of taste.
- Literally what our
job is here at Buzzfeed.
Tasting.
- Yeah.
- The aftertaste does taste
like an espresso or something.
- Yeah.
- It definitely tastes fresh.
- Oh, it's very good.
It's a solid bagel.
- Good, but a little too bitter.
I feel like if,
I think the cream cheese would help.
- Yeah.
- For sure.
(bang)
- I think this is gonna
taste good because,
you say, it's like you
can taste the bitterness,
sort of, of the espresso.
So then, like cream cheese,
which would give all that sweet
flavor to it, would be nice.
(crunching)
- Mmm, I like it with the cream cheese.
- Mmmhmm.
- Mmm, delicious.
- You can't go wrong with
cream cheese, really.
- (laughs) that's true!
- Oh yeah, that's really good.
- I actually would really like
this with a cup of coffee.
I feel like that would be like
the perfect compliment to it.
- I feel like I feel more awake,
but I know that's placebo.
- I actually do love this.
- I do, I really do love it.
- Yeah, it's a good
bagel, especially for LA.
- Mmmhmm.
- Usually LA bagels are garbage
so, this is pretty good.
But not enough caffeine, for my taste.
- I don't think it's gonna
effect me like that much.
I feel like this is more of like,
a thing that I will eat with my coffee.
- For me it's not useful
to have a third of a cup
of coffee in a bagel,
so yeah, I'd probably
want it to be stronger.
(mischievous music)
- So, it's been about an hour
since I had the coffee bagel,
and I feel like, pretty awake.
'Bout like a half a cup of coffee.
So, it works.
- It's been about three hours
since we had the Espresso Buzz bagel,
or whatever the hell it's called.
And, ya know, I have some energy still.
Ya know, I feel like it's
just been sustaining me
throughout the whole day.
- I never really felt anything,
other than full.
- Would eat it again,
but, need more coffee.
- To be honest, they
taste pretty good to me,
but I don't feel energized
from eating them.
I feel like I do still need
to get my coffee intake.
- I haven't had any coffee today
other than basically the bagel,
and I'm not tired.
Usually at this time
I need a cup of coffee to
wake up and actually work,
but right now, I'm not tired at all.
- One thing I have noticed though,
is that it's been making
me poop a little bit more.
Which I know coffee does to me sometimes.
So yeah, I've been poopin'
more too because of it.
Good job bagel!
- [Garrett] Are there any other
liquids you can see making,
being turned into a bagel?
- [Jordan] Oh, Kool-Aid, for sure.
- A Kool-Aid bagel, get on it!